Star Trek beyond is directed by Justin
Lin the man behind the most recent Fast
& Furious films and the best I might add
and it stars all these people all these
people are in the movies tons of people
I'm not there all there in this movie
you knew that already due to a series of
catastrophic events to the enterprise it
crashed lands on a planet where all of
the Enterprise crew are scattered as
they try to survive from the evil wrath
of crawl played by idris elba who's
after a very specific piece of
technology that has been hidden away on
the enterprise for many years his
reasons for wanting this device are
unclear but what is absolutely crystal
clear is that he's an evil person he's
gonna kill everybody and it's not good
the trailers for this movie were
underwhelming to say the least and I'm a
big Star Trek fan so that's not good
anyone who didn't give a about Star
Trek definitely didn't give a about
this movie when they saw the trailers
for it the poster campaign however was
awesome no posters for this movie were
really exciting so I didn't really know
what to think I'll tell you what this is
proof positive once again the trailers
really don't mean trailers are just
a marketing tool to get us into the
movie in the end though what really
matters the film and this one was damn
good
this surprised me really big surprise
Star Trek beyond is an absolute blast I
was entertained from opening to close
this was a ton of fun to theater a big
summer blockbuster with all the things
you want to see explosions and fun
action sequences good characters with
good humor and a respect for the
original this movie is celebrating the
50th anniversary of Star Trek and it
does it very well not only because it's
a very entertaining fast paced Star Trek
adventure but because it does pay
respect to the original cast to the
original crew it does have an affinity
for it and you can feel it through
almost every scene in this movie a few
in particular that actually made me tear
up and it was a happy crime it was just
like a warm good feeling that you don't
get that often in movies Chris Pine and
Zachary Quinto are both once again
fantastic as Kirk and Spock I loved
seeing these characters on the screen
but what I really liked about beyond is
that the previous two films have really
explored Kirk in Spock's relationship
this one really gave a lot of time
I'm too Spock and bones played by Karl
Urban because these two characters get
separated from everyone else and they
have to make their way through this
wilderness of this odd planet they're on
and they have a lot of dialogue together
and the dialogue for them is really good
classic Spock and bones stuff and a lot
of this is written by Simon Pegg and his
writing partner and I was genuinely very
impressed with their writing because
this movie has a great feeling of
character because the most important
things about the Star Trek movies no
matter what you want to say it's the
characters Star Trek movies stopped
being very original a long time ago
because there's really only so much you
can do with the space ship and a crew
and aliens and the galaxies and stuff
what makes these movies special are the
characters what keeps us coming back to
these movies are the characters and this
movie is well aware that because there's
a ton of character depth woven
throughout this movie it's not just a
lot of fun action it is a damn
entertaining movie that knows how to be
a summer blockbuster but also build
character and that is great to see Idris
Elba plays the main bad guy this movie
and of course he's in her Selva so he's
pretty badass as this character the
character is not given quite as much
depth as you would want for a long
portion of the movie and for the
majority of the movie I was like he's
fine as a character in her shell but was
great as his character he did a lot of
really cool stuff with his voice I don't
know how much of that was post sound
work but I thought he was great as this
menacing person who's after this device
and you bought into his character but
there wasn't much going on there and you
were sort of murky on his entire
motivation until the third act no
spoilers but then I was like okay
there's okay
yeah I can get behind that so when
you're watching this movie during the
first two acts if you're feeling like
he's kind of a villain wait patience is
a virtue but easily my favorite new
addition to this movie is the character
of Jayla this is one badass woman oh my
god she was cool I loved her character
she looked awesome the makeup work was
fantastic she was a fun character that
had good humor woven throughout her but
she could also kick a lot of ass which
is really fun to see but she was never
annoying she never overstayed her
welcome there wasn't anything about her
character that bugged me she was just
awesome so
I like this one as much as the other two
no I don't I think it's my least
favorite of this trilogy for a few
reasons number one being that the first
act is a bit meandering it takes a while
to get the movie really going at least
for me there are fun things to look at
and it's never boring but it just didn't
hook me until the second act and then
the third act got even better this is
that rare movie where each act builds
upon the last and for me got better as
it went along that's hard to do usually
a movie peeks at one point or peeks at
the end and but isn't that good in the
beginning or it Peaks in the middle or
something this movie has a steady
incline of Awesomeness Justin Lin
genuinely surprised me the action is not
quite as intense and the laser edged in
regards to how visceral JJ Abrams
directs his films but the smaller
character moments are well realized the
script respects the original characters
as well as these new characters it
understands the Star Trek mythos and it
understands how to make a fun Star Trek
movie this is an extremely good and fun
Star Trek film that for me wasn't quite
as good as those first two and does not
have as compelling a villain as Benedict
Cumberbatch was and into darkness star
trek beyond was a blast it's a very good
summer movie it's a good Star Trek movie
and I'm going to give it an A - also I
just want to say rest in peace Leonard
Nimoy you are a legend and rest in peace
Antoine Yelchin gone way too soon guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to this weekend and the
return of the retro rewind segment I'm
gonna be talking about one of my
favorite classic childhood shows are you
afraid of the dark you guys are the best
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes